each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so welcome to the first plenary session
of the microsoft software summit ER in
paris it's wonderful to have so many
faces that i know here and also so many
faces that we don't know and that we
will get to know over the next three
days later on this afternoon i'll give
you a few of the stats about the people
who are here but right now this is just
a call to order and the person who is
going to actually introduce and welcome
you all to the software summit is Andrew
Herbert now Andrea is chairman of
microsoft research for Europe the Middle
Eastern Africa and in this position he
oversees all the technical strategy and
political policy engagements in this
region he's responsible for engagement
with politicians officials and
professional and industry bodies as many
of you heard this morning and their
strategy advice initially he joined
Microsoft Research in 2001 as assistant
director and then he succeeded the
existing the then director roger Needham
in March 2003 and his current role he
started in November last year and so it
gives me great pleasure to introduce my
distinguished and great friend and you
Herbert thank you
so hopefully this see this will be my
slides selector AB my own words of
welcome to this our first European
software summit and looking forward to
spending time with you throughout the
remainder of this week talking about
current themes and issues in computer
science research obviously we'd like to
highlight some of the things that we do
in Microsoft Research in Europe and at
our other laboratories thank you my
beautiful assistant is arranging my
slides for me we how many years have we
known each other I think the first time
when I was a junior faculty member and
you were as well when you came with
sparkling in Cambridge we're very proud
of the research presence that we have
here in Europe
our incredible partnership between the
connect team and microsoft research has
allowed us to make tomorrow happen today
the feedback that we've got from users
about photo fuse has been amazing I mean
no we couldn't have brought this feature
to our users without the collaboration
with microsoft research
what's fun about microsoft research is
that we're constantly exploring you're
looking for the best ideas we're taking
things that people thought were
improbable and making them possible and
then taking them all the way to reality
so very quick snapshot of a Microsoft
Research and the challenge is how many
of the people in that video will you
recognize from their talks later on in
the event today so I'd like to welcome
you to our software summit this is the
first software summit that we've had in
Europe our aim in putting on this event
and its find an opportunity to talk to
you about some of the research we do
what we see as some of the important
themes and challenges where there are
opportunities for collaboration we'd
like to learn about the research that
you're doing that is complementary and
that we can leverage together we've also
starting with the workshops that we had
this morning and running as a theme
through some of the discussions it's
also talked about shared concerns around
topics like research funding how
students should be taught the strength
of European Science and priorities and
so forth very much like to see this as
building on conversations many of us
have already using the summit to pull
those together and if this event is a
success as I very much hope it will be
something that we can repeat them and do
again in other cities and other parts of
Europe as a a regular event and to help
stimulate and drive forward the the
community so let me just tell you a
little bit about microsoft research as
an organization many of the faces I see
in the audience are very familiar you
know this well but I also see some new
ones we are Microsoft's corporate
research facility where a independent
division within the company we're
centrally funded and our mission is to
do basic research in computer science we
have six main labs across the the planet
in the major geographical regions in the
USA redmond is the original and oldest
the Microsoft laboratories that has his
20th anniversary in the autumn of this
year the European lab is in Cambridge in
England where the Jude said I was
managing director until recently and now
I've handed over to my colleague Andrew
bleak or ensure he's going to take the
Cambridge lab on to even greater and
better places than I was able to do we
were the first overseas laboratory
created when the rebel lab was five
years old so we're just approaching our
15th and others
three and the motivation to have a lab
in Europe was very clear to tap into the
European talent pool a recognition that
their areas of computer science in which
Europe had had great strength which
accompanied my croissant eded access and
indeed a recognition that there are
unique things about the the European
market that we wanted about access and
understand if you think back 15 years
that was the time when Europeans had
cell phones and they worked and
Americans barely had them in major
cities and I remember back in those days
standing on the mobile phone on the
Great Wall of China floating my wife and
one for an experience it was one of my
American colleagues complaining that his
mobile phone couldn't even be used
within one city to phone the suburb was
his family lived things have changed
since then but I think there are many
areas of Technology where Europe still
has a very strong leadership role and
the fact that we are a very moulton
multicultural society I think brings us
many interesting opportunities as well
we were followed a year later by our
colleagues in Beijing our Asia lab and
then more recently and we've added our
lab in Bangalore in India following the
economic growth and emergence of those
countries we have to further smaller
laboratories in the u.s. these days we
have one in Silicon Valley and as you
might imagine that lab came into
existence as Internet technologies
became more and more important for
Microsoft and just to confuse everyone
we have a lab in the other Cambridge
came across a chusetts as they got there
a bit late they have to call themselves
Microsoft Research New England and some
of you you may know there's a famous
University called Harvard Inc a
Massachusetts and Harvard was a
Cambridge England graduate so it all
gets very very confusing those are our
main labs and if I drill down into
Europe we have some very deep
partnerships with a number of
institutions where we've put together
joint research centers where we were
working together for for many years now
starting with with here in Paris we've
had a very strong partnership with a
morir the French national computer
science laboratories we have a joint
center just outside Paris in sare one of
the the new clusters that's being
developed that's where we do a great
deal of joint research on topics like
software verification theorem proving
applications are computer science to
scientific computation human cooter
action a wide range of areas and you
find a mixture of a morir Microsoft
researchers working together with
jointly funded postdocs and PhD students
that's been a very exciting venture
we've always had a very strong
collaboration within brain it's been
nice to manifest that as a center I
don't know many people here attended
their forum where they presented their
results yesterday and that's that's been
a very successful organization in
addition and we have a joint center with
the University of trento in Italy this
is focused on computational systems
biology this is using computer science
models to model biological systems at
the scale of the human cell up to
ecosystems are a min that investment
which also think about six years old now
was to help bootstrap new capability and
capacity in Europe building around a
very strong research collaborator
Corrado pre army that has been very
successful and alongside our investment
help them get start started they've had
fantastic investment from the European
Union from various scientific
foundations and so forth and are now
operating on a much more independent
basis which is fantastic to see I think
one of the roles of industries to help
get you things started we have a very
good collaboration with the polytechnic
university in catalonia of catalonia in
barcelona where we work together on
issues around parallel computing and
where we bring together our expertise
perhaps more on the software side with
their expertise more on the hardware
side and look at that hardware software
interface and interesting at though the
focus it is parallel computation and
many people know if Barcelona as the
home of a supercomputer one of the
projects there is vector graphics
processing for mobile phones so bringing
some of those ideas down to smaller
scale systems to so those collaborations
are very important to us and the orange
dot on the screen is another laboratory
which reports into my organization a
European Microsoft innovation center in
Arkin where we look at technologies for
embedded systems and real-time and
embedded systems particular focus on the
automotive sector
thinking about how cars will will
connect and leverage Internet services
we rode today now high entertainment
satellite navigation certain amount of
maintenance and monitoring of our mental
sensing traffic management building on
those technologies and finally but by no
means least we have our Innovation
Center in Cairo in Egypt it's been an
exciting time for employees in that
laboratory in recent months their focus
is looking at research into technologies
that allow the company to deliver its
products and services particularly in
the Arabic world other that very rapidly
generalizes into other cultures that
rely on complex scripts and so a lot of
work on natural language processing
content management how you get content
in other than Western languages on to
the World Wide Web how you do
multilingual searching and so forth so
very large rd presence both of our own
laboratories and our advanced
development centers like our command
cairo and our academic collaborations so
i take you into our cambridge laboratory
this is our building for about two more
years where we're commissioning a new
building those as those you who visitors
will be pleased to know the new building
is near at the railway station it's in
the old freight yard of the railway
station in fact and if you come visiting
Cambridge in the next few weeks you can
see the demolition of the old building
before a new one is erect in its place
and we've been moving in 2012 so the
mission for all the microsoft research
labs is very simple this mission was set
by rick rashid when he was hired to
create the Microsoft Research
Organization unusually for industry
we've kept the same mission statement
throughout our history we've carefully
avoided changing it the company has
changed around us but the mission seems
always to put us in good position and it
starts with a research objective that
I'm sure every academic in this room of
resonate with our goal is to advance the
state of the art in computer science we
research things that interest us some
are driven by curiosity a desire to
scuffin to discover new things some are
are driven more by an application people
want to see how technology can be
developed to solve a specific problem
often those two
means feed off each other in interesting
and fascinating ways and our model of
how we conduct our research hire smart
people put them in the laboratory given
the resources they need and then as
management we try and stay out of the
way where we come and help them more is
particularly with the the second part of
our mission which is to make sure we
transfer the the knowledge the
understanding the technologies that come
from that research into the Microsoft
products and business groups to help
help make sure that Microsoft remains a
competitive and powerful company in the
industry and indeed if you ask senior
executives from other divisions of
Microsoft why does the company invest in
basic research they will explain our
existence by pointing to things in our
track record that have had an impact on
the company it was Microsoft Research
who helped the company adopt the tcp/ip
protocols it was microsoft research that
helped build the companies for a search
engine and realize that having our own
one might actually be important to us it
was Microsoft Research who invented in
3d computer graphics which is the
foundation of the Xbox business and
increasingly what we're doing in the PC
world and as a whole raft of other
important technologies in products
indeed several business divisions in
Microsoft that essentially were
incubated in research and so we're
measured as I exhaust pipe our impact
and as lab directors our model is to
hire the best research as we can in the
hope that they will keep putting your
things in that pipe lighting plan and we
have that nice for a 35 year lag in
which the the company trusts us with the
research initiatives we undertake and so
our mission as an organization really is
going to capture by the the last bullet
am which is about leading Microsoft into
the future and that includes doing
things and our laboratories which today
might even seem disruptive or hostile to
the company understanding other
approaches to solving problems
understanding competitive ideas things
that might be complete changes in how
the business is done obviously
understanding disruptive technologies
and getting to grips with those things
so that when the company comes to
compete with those things or adopt them
or responsive in some way research can
help
do that so our culture is one which will
be very familiar to anyone who's who's
worked in a leading academic institution
we hire smart people we very much let
them work on the projects they want to
our organizational structures are very
light we we loosely group people into
teams based around their their
intellectual interests the cambridge
march i know best we subscribe in terms
of five areas research around
programming around machine learning
around systems and networks around
fidelity living around computational
science but those are very broad labels
at any point in time there are lots of
projects going on some projects have
named some projects don't have names
there's no full mechanism for joining a
project or leaving a project and part of
the challenges as a lab director or a
chairman for the area is updating your
slide deck at about the same speed at
which the chat the researchers are
changing the research program it can be
interesting challenge most of our
researchers come to us from academia
either as young postdocs or established
figures who want to come and spend time
working industry and seeing their
research having an impact on products
and systems that people use obviously we
also have some colleagues who come to us
from other industry laboratories and we
have a very strong relationship of
partnering collaboratively with
colleagues in universities worldwide
obviously Europe is the center of
gravity that it's easier to collaborate
with people who are next door the people
who thousands of miles away from but our
outlook is it is entirely global and if
I talk about collaboration much of it is
informal its people visiting its
students coming as interns some bit is
certainly funded through the microsoft
research connections programs and indeed
this event is being run and organised
forest by the microsoft research
connections team i like to very much
thank them for that that's the
organization headed by my good friend
and colleague Tony hey and they run out
a more formal programs for collaboration
and funding and so forth and we try and
make sure that the informal side and the
formal side overlap and work well in
partnership and obviously part of this
event is to help you learn more about
those
and become more engaged and give us
feedback on how we could make these
things work more effectively for you as
well as getting the results from them
that we want so why are we in Europe why
is Europe be important to us and there
is deep scientific and engineering
expertise people who came to the panel I
ran this morning about research funding
I think many of the speakers showed us
statistics that demonstrated that
European research is very strong very
vibrant often amongst the most efficient
in the world if you measure it in terms
of citations out four dollars put in we
have many challenges in the current
financial context and so forth we are I
think very strong into spring research
we have to thank the European Union for
some of its programs that are broken
down barriers between countries made it
easier to collaborate made it easier for
people to move around and encourage the
strong sense of collaboration and
interaction between industry and
university which is is to our strengths
and so that connectedness is is very
important and then the diversity the
great thing about Europe is it many of
us we enjoy our own national
characteristics we joke with each other
about the strange nature of the British
and the French and the Germans and the
Italians indeed one fled to the Saudi
exit while you ask the swish you gave a
a Swiss German list for questions so I
now answer every one of your questions
there are people other nationalities who
chose to answer a different set of
questions that's how it works them we
enjoy that diversity and richness and I
think that is important technology is
now global and therefore the
technologies we develop have to respect
and understand how to live in diverse
environments what are the impact
different cultures and it's deeper than
just your language and so forth what is
the role of Technology in different
societies than just those of the other
developed world so that's very important
to us so I'm not going to read the
program to just talk about its broad
shape we're starting with the keynote
from my colleague kenwood and I think my
second or third hire I'm not sure into
the Cambridge laboratory and find very
early on in my days as managing effect
oh my jesus was all the managing
director he's going to give us a keynote
on what lies beyond software we do quite
a lot
hardware research in the Cambridge
laboratory and and how people interact
with the technology can we'll talk about
that we then divide into sessions and so
please pick your tracks which one will
interest you semantic computation on
software agents parallelism how we can
bring theory and practice together and a
third track on massively parallel
systems and I think these are all very
important agendas certainly one of my
sensations is we're seeing significant
changes in the computing landscape
driven by cloud computing driven by
multi-core we're grappling with having
lots of things going on in our systems
gives us huge challenges and how we
program those things how we think about
a ksiva of the software systems and so
those three sessions i think will cover
much of that territory then at the end
of the day we have a panel where a group
of us will be invited to try and guess
what we'll be talking about 20 years
from now so I take that as a vote of
confidence from my colleagues and
microsoft research connections that will
be doing this in 20 years time and could
be held to account for what we said but
I suspect I might be retired by then and
then this evening we have buses taking
us to a a cruise on the scene with
dinner which I'm looking forward to it
should be great fun tomorrow we start
with a key wrote keynote for my
colleague wall for a shorter and he'll
talk to us about software engineering
research in Microsoft Research let his
vision of the future of that then break
out into three sessions again with more
of a focus on a web and cloud and a
particular panel looking at the embedded
application area in particular focus to
my colleagues in our Archon laboratory
although they have many partnerships
with colleagues in Cambridge work and
things like they're improving and so
forth after that we have a lot of
demonstrations hopefully you'll visit
those talk to the researchers and
interact a third session looking at
naturals interfaces looking at handling
some of the the data challenges and
looking at how we can do experimental
work to drive forward the agenda in
software verification and indeed
convince other developers they should be
using these techniques getting over that
user barrier I think it's very hard
that a second session naturally surveys
tools how we put tools in the hand of
students and the verification theme
continues as a second half and then we
close and you're your own discretion as
to how you spend the evening on the
second day then we wrap up on the third
day again a mix session bugs
reconfigurable computing verifying
systems programs keynote on open source
where that fits in in that world that's
always been an interesting topic forest
in Microsoft and I'm sure many of you
have seen the Microsoft corporate
position open soft change significantly
over the time I've been with the company
as I'm not taking credit for that change
I have also seen that change and we have
a nice talk there from Brendan Eich of
Mozilla call and Tony he'll talk about
the Microsoft view of this then we have
workshop tutorial & A panel and we
closed the event at five o'clock so i
hope you'll find the the summit useful
and worthwhile I sure like many events
they'll be as much value if not more in
the coffee breaks and the and the
lunches and the evening events and the
lectures away you sit back and relax and
learn something new to build up your
energy for the next conversation with
colleagues and the brakes so the next
speaker is Ken boards and talk about
beyond software I believe Judith you're
going to do the introductions
okay so it's my great pleasure now to
introduce kenwood and Ken of course is
the deputy managing director at the same
lab as andrew is and he has the also the
distinction of heading up a division
there which I will tell you about but in
his capacity as deputy managing director
at Microsoft's research lab he is
responsible for the labs business is
facing activities including technology
transfer incubation and licensing
spinouts and other models of
intellectual property so he also
oversees the labs marketing and
communication activities the lab that he
does head up is the communicate sorry
the computer mediated living research
group caml which he founded in 2003
which is quite a long time ago and from
that he's going to tell us quite a bit
about what has happened in that lab and
it's fundamentally interdisciplinary
bringing together hardware engineering
computer science psychology and
sociology to address the problems of
designing innovative technology of today
from these kinds of things we have had
amazing work in Microsoft Research which
have has enabled us to make great
strides and some of those will be
announced during the course of this
summit so keep your ears pinned to the
ground and meanwhile it is going to be
my pleasure to invite 10 to come up
thank you Ken
thank you very much Judith I noticed the
running slightly behind time salt on it
oh you want to give the the break the
big thing here so good like this and
then that's going off and I'm gonna go
to you yeah then we go there there we go
fund me I believe it's on is it is on I
thought I had drunk back on yeah it's on
here can you hear me yes okay thank you
right thank you very much today what I
really want to talk about is software
which is not surprising since we're at a
software summit but really what I want
to talk about is the kind of
technological landscape that software
sits in and how the the evolution of
that landscape changes the way that we
need to think about what software does
in a very rapidly changing technological
landscape so as a little exercise I
thought we just should take a look at
really how this landscape has changed I
think a lot of us we're all in this
field a lot of us have done this
exercise mentally if not written it down
over the years but it's nonetheless
worthwhile to go through this and think
about how things have changed so when I
was an undergraduate starting at Harvard
in the early 80s I did most of my
programming on a PDP 1170 macro 11
coding on a PDP 1170 and now in my
pocket I'm carrying around that phone so
in today's dollars a pdp-11 would cost
about 62,000 dollars now to be to be
generous the phone would cost of what
500 probably less than that if you get
it on something to package of course but
so worth about five hundred dollars it's
a factor of a hundred and twenty for
this phone is 124 times cheaper than the
pdp-11 that I used when I was starting
out they didn't really measure these
things then but roughly the pdp-11 was a
20 megahertz machine in my phone I've
got a 1 gigahertz processor that's a
factor of 50 you multiply those two
things six thousand times more CPU
cycles per dollar on this thing on King
around in my pocket then in that GDP
level 128 k of memory in the pdp-11 and
that's being generous because only 64
hey of it was addressable how much
memory if I got in my pocket nine
gigabytes of memory a gig of around
eight gigs of flash seventy thousand
times as much memory as in that pdp-11
is in my phone seventy thousand times as
you can see the peak 11 was as big as a
fridge maybe slightly bigger my phone is
not as we the fridge it's it's in my
pocket mouse pdp-11 much heavier than a
fridge my phone 130 grams I can put it
in any any of my pockets and not even
know what's there so just think about
this even those of us in the field at
least I find this I am continually
amazed at how much things have changed
the processing power we're all carrying
around in our pockets is just infinitely
in fridge sighs heavier than fringes
much less powerful things but that's not
all that's not all folks it's a phone
there's radios all over this thing
there's a there's a 3g radio there's
bluetooth radio there's a Wi-Fi radio
your phone can talk to almost any other
computing device on the planet one way
or another through the cloud
peer-to-peer it's just incredible what
has happened what your kangaroo is just
phenomenal and so I want us to think
about that and to think about what that
means for software and I try I've been
thinking about this for a while I'm
trying to think about how to articulate
this so I think what we want to ask
ourselves is what is software now I know
a lot of us in fact I've met one of my
one of my old colleagues who looks at
this a lot of us in the past have looked
at software as a mathematical construct
what can we r having me reasoned about
it what it does some of us think about
how it impacts how we build operating
systems for computers of various types I
want to take a higher level view of that
and just think that at any given point
in time there is a boundary of the
technology that we have there's a
certain amount stuff that we could do if
we use if we use the if the technology
as well as we could we can only get to a
certain place and software is what lets
us take that technological material that
we have to hand and turn it into
something turn it into something for
people now in the old days in the sort
of Doss area which is also just that the
latter end of the pdp-11 type II era we
really could only talk about turning
that technological material into into
solutions to problems we were solving
things when I was running my macro 11
code was mainly writing simulations to
generate single numbers that were
answers to problems that that kind of
thing but as the technology has moved
along as we've got toward this phase
it's much more about generating
experiences for people so software isn't
is an agent for turning the
technological material of the day into
experiences so just in order to give you
one small illustration of that let me
turn to my colleague Tim Regan and play
a little video of Tim's about a project
we did in the computer mediated living
group a few years ago now is it called
grab and share so I'm going to turn it
over to Tim briefly hope this works and
just hello I'd like to show you grabbin
share
approach type we've been working on
recently in your hula we've been
involved with the broadcast and the
transmission industries looking at
mobile TV and mobile video and one of
the things that struck us as researchers
was the way in which mobile video was
used as social capital in people's
day-to-day lives for example you might
take a video with you when you meet your
friends show it to them and share a
laugh with them as one would joke so we
built grab and share to explore that
idea let me show you it imagine you're
sat at home watching TV and a clip comes
up that you know a friend would enjoy
you can now browse to that clip on your
mobile phone and then download it in
this scenario the friend then turns up
and you can go and greet them at the
door and then show them the clip if they
like it they may ask for a copy and grab
and share allows you to send it to them
over bluetooth once they have it they
can play it or share it with their
friends as well so that's grab and share
and I hope it shows you that mobile TV
as well as moving TV in terms of time or
place that you can watch it also adds a
social dimension new social scenarios
that were lacking from fixed TV thank
you mobile video as social capital
that's what Tim said early on another
mobile video as social capital think
about that even 10 years ago much less
20 years ago we couldn't have conceived
of a Eva of an application like that
where mobile video in itself was just as
in its infancy but the idea of being
able to easily pass it around and subtly
notice that there was an interaction
between the video that was on the
broadcast TV and the video in his pocket
that happened in the cloud so there's a
whole cloud thing going on to enable
that what seems to us relatively simple
application mobile video as social
capital is an experience that
we couldn't have thought about
generating earlier and it's essentially
generated by software bridging that gap
between well that taking us somewhere
along that spectrum of what we can do
with the technology that we have so we
go back to this graph the other aspect
of this you see that the yellow line
which kind of represents what we what
software generates for us goes up and
down because in any given era what we
have to hand we can be good or bad at
writing software to take advantage of
that and generate what are now
experiences and at all so in any given
at any given time there is a space
between the yellow and the blue lines
which are things that we could do but we
haven't done and another point that I
wanted is that space is getting enormous
because the blue curve is just going is
going up in the sky so quickly that what
we can do is almost limitless and so we
now have to start sort of thing about
what we should do and one of the things
that I want to talk about as well as how
we can make it easier to to decide what
we what we should do that's going to be
part of my talk later but let me also
let me turn now to another experience
just to say that they don't all have to
be about small portable devices you've
all heard of the Microsoft Surface I
assume but if not it's a a multi-touch
interactive table top computer that you
can see somebody designing it a
skateboard with there now this isn't
actually a cutaway of the surface but it
could be this is a cutaway of an
advanced to the surface that we've done
in the Cambridge lab called second
language I'll tell you about in a bit
but to explain just in case you don't
know the way that the surface works is
there's a translucent table top surface
and underneath it a PC a projector and a
camera the pc projects the output of our
sort of the the projector projects the
output of the pc onto the screen that
you see at your table top the camera
let's um the your finger touches on the
translucent screen be seen and used as
input to the pc and you can then
interact with the pc now the point I
wanted to make here with this is that I
told you how fantastically fast
computing technology was advancing in
that first slide but there
also advances that go hand in hand with
that to let us do things that aren't
necessarily just about electronics and
in this case it was a piece of materials
science that gave us a little edge to
try and do something different because
on second light on the microsoft surface
the surface is simply a a a translucent
piece of plastic essentially in second
light it's a piece of very special
material that in one state is a piece of
translucent plastic but by applying an
electrical current to it becomes
completely clear and that can happen a
hundred and twenty times a second so we
thought about what could we maybe do
with that what experiences could be
generated with that so I've got a little
video it's a little bit dim but I'll
play this for you and you can get an
idea for what that enables so what you
should see it first this is going to
work and it's not going to work let's
try it again here we go so you can see
somebody interacting with this surface
drawing on the surface which is and
that's that's the kind of thing which
you can do with an ordinary microsoft
surface tribe you can you can basically
interact with it using your fingers on
the surface and more than one person can
do it once you can use more than one
finger at once and so on and it can show
images on a surface to see an image of
flowers on on the surface but second
light can show images through with
surface as well so what you see there is
a an ordinary piece of translucent
tracing paper and importantly you can
see that when the tracing paper was on
the surface there was an a different
image and image of sharks but even when
you pick the paper up you still see the
image of the Sharks on the paper it's
really quite magical when you see this
happen and even more magical is that it
can do these things at the same time so
there you see the image of the Sharks on
the paper the image of the flowers
underneath them at the same time as you
move the paper around really quite
amazing now because I've kind of given
the trick away as to how this works but
all oh what the explanation come to very
quickly so basically now we have two
projectors underneath two cameras for
reasons that I don't need to go into and
that electrically switchable thing at
the top which can go from clear to
translucent 120 times a second and so
all we do is when it's clear we're
shining one image and when it's opaque
shani another so you see you can see two
completely different interactive
experiences on something that's held
that's that's on the surface and
something something something that's
held above it so there's some
applications of this the so-called magic
lenses so you can imagine you've got a
photograph of the night sky you throw a
frosted glass disk down and you can look
through you can you can overlay the
diagram of the constellations on top of
that photograph of the night sky or you
can be designing a car you can see the
external part of the car these magic
lenses can be used to look to the
interior and these are just ordinary
things so there we put a frosted glass
disk and a piece of tracing paper down
and both of those give you access to the
internals of the young and there's some
fun things that you can do you can take
a translucent prism object and you can
you can you know you can imagine what
we're doing there you can do also to fun
things with with physical objects link
to the two but this is probably the most
interesting so remember this thing is
clear half the time so you can see
through it if you're underneath that you
can see through it half the time so we
can we can actually track your hands not
just when they're touching the surface
but when they're above it and that lets
us do the following so I hope you can
see this well but you can see that the
person's hands remain held above the
screen and we're still interacting there
now the magic lenses thing is really it
r is it is quite magical to see doesn't
seem to me that that's a real killer
application of this there is a killer
application though which is 3d
interaction 3d rendering is becoming
much more common it's very easy to get
packages what you can design 3d objects
you can render them but interaction
techniques for 3d on a 2d system are
actually not so well thought of and if
you think about it if you had a ordinary
surface computer and you want it to put
one of those balls in the cup what would
the interaction paradigm be how could
how could you do it you you really
couldn't let me just play this'll video
you'll see what i mean so so this person
is using the 2d interaction techniques
to push balls around on the surface but
if he wants to pick a ball up and put it
in the cup how can you do it well you'll
see in a second this is looking up
through the thing
when the thing is clear we can see your
hands we can use ray level estimation to
know roughly how high his hands are and
we can look at gestures say we can
easily detect a pinch gesture like that
so suddenly we have we can we can we can
generate a very easy interaction
technique for picking something up a 3d
object up and dropping it down as you'll
see just in second so you can lift up
the ball put over the cup and drop it in
hey presto and I think this is amazing
but I think this is something where a
sort of small advance in some ways in
materials science coupled with that
tremendous advancing computational power
that I've been talking about because
that's key here to generates another set
of new experiences along that line so
well this actually just has this sort of
as a kind of a side in my abstract I
mentioned that I'd be talking about
hardware projects that we're doing in
the lab where we want to get the
hardware out of the lab in it and into
people's hands second light is actually
one of those projects so it's proved to
be a little there's there's some sort of
regulatory issues too that's a big
power-hungry thing but nonetheless we
people in some academics in Barcelona
already have one of these units to
experiment with and if you're interested
in this area you know get it get it get
in touch with us because it's one of the
things that we want to do this whole
idea about the hardware software
boundary we want to get other people
working in this area so so do get in
touch so now back to the regularly
scheduled program things have changed I
think I'll keep making about things
really really have changed so back in
the area when I was at my VT 220 doing
Mac relevant programming on the pdp-11
through the simple PC era where we have
the you know 64k pcs with the with the
ASCII output through modern pcs where we
have that same phenomenal level of
computational power in this case in our
brief cases to a new world where there
are tons of different computing devices
things do not necessarily even think of
a computing device like your car which
certainly is a computing device of the
first order all talking to each other
and all of them so when I think we're in
is a world of gadgets or the gadget is
often thought of as something small that
you turn your pocket like your tone it
could be but you know second light can
be a gadget it's some new type of
largely electronic thing which does
something talking to other
no trumpets we're in a world of gadgets
and one of the projects in the computer
mediated living group is called
Gadgeteer and that's what I want to talk
mainly about today gadget here is about
building gadgets we want to make it easy
to build gadgets in this new world that
we're so we have a toolkit for quickly
constructing programming and shaping and
i'll get to that that's quite important
new computing devices or gadgets and we
want to be able to go from idea that you
have to a working device as easy and as
quickly as possible we want there to be
a very low threshold it should be very
easy to build a simple device a child
should be able to build a simple device
in fact children have used vegetable
some of the vices but it should have a
high ceiling we should be able to build
very complex things that interact with
other devices in complex ways to form
part of this new ecosystem that i'm
talking about those are two goals and i
think we I think that we largely achieve
those so there are three components to
gadget here I'm going to talk about all
three I should actually add another
little site here about 20 of you
attended a gadget here tutorial this
morning so you all know more about this
than I do so I apologize right now for
us for anything that i might get that
but i might get wrong but I'm very
pleased that there are those ideas that
did attend the tutorial this morning but
the three components of this are modular
hardware so bits of hard with our easy
to plug and play together software in
this case a very nice object-oriented
ide supported programming system to let
you program these these these gadgets at
a high level and very interestingly 3d
modeling let's make it easy to put these
gadgets in nice houses make them easy
easy to hold a news so there's those
three aspects
I've Gadgeteer we initially built gadget
here largely as a tool for ourselves in
MSR because in the group that Judith
mentioned that i found a few years ago
and continue to run the computer
mediated living group when you really
like to to think up new gadgets or new
new ways of interacting and when we do
that we want to get real instantiations
of that new technique or new idea into
people's hands and see how they react to
and so in order to do that we have to
build things and gadget here is one way
that we can build those even so it was
for our own purposes initially but since
then other researchers have become very
interested in it so we've been getting
other people to to use it in the same
vein we do but also we've had a lot of
interest from hobbyists and educators we
took it to the Maker Faire last year I
think Nick and talking more about that
and it was tremendously popular you know
it's almost like the hobbyist era of the
pc we're getting really interested in
what they can build with this stuff and
so we're now working actively on getting
gadgeteer out of the lab and into into
the hands of people in the wider world
and i'll tell you more about what's
happening on that front later but it's
going you know it's going very well just
take a drink here
so the heart of the gadget system is
this modular hardware platform that
allows the modules to be easily easily
connected to each other to form new new
functional gadgets and each of the
module adds some sort of capability
right now we can add up we can add new
modules all the time as well but you can
imagine modules to take pictures to play
sounds to sense the environment to talk
to other devices all of these things to
enable user interaction are all are all
needed the core of the thing is a
relatively low puppet as in terms of
compared to my phone even arm core with
number was quite a lot of memory off of
it and the idea is that it has a number
of sockets at the moment I think we may
have added 10 to the labeled a 30 and
basically if you have when you when you
build a new module it will be on one of
a few types of standard interfaces
labeled with the corresponding letter
and you can plug that module into any
available socket that has that same
letter up we tried to mix and match
those so the the the number of types of
modules that you would usually want to
plug in roughly roughly lines up but
there's no soldiering involved you just
plug and play and away you go so what
are the modules that we built so far
there's there's pretty number the main
two are the main board that I has talked
about and the USB device this one is one
that there's three things it provides
power to the unit and I'll tell you more
about why its power comes from the
outside of the moment or at least it did
until recently it provides a programming
interface so you can you can write
software to run these things and it also
makes the the the mainboard thing that
you're building look like a USB device
to the outside world which can be which
would confuse there's a bunch of user
out of user interface elements so the
other USB devices one that actually
allows you to plug other USB devices
into the gadget that you're building up
for USB host but there's a bunch of
ordinary sort of you like I think
there's a simple button interface
there's LEDs that you can turn on and
off there's an and an OLED display
there's a touchscreen that isn't shown
here but we have little touch screen and
there's rotary switches d pads which are
those sort of gamepad style switches for
four weeks which is
so a bunch of those there are sensor
modules there's a light level RGB sensor
there's an ultrasonic ranger temperature
and humidity a burglar alarm style
passive IR sensor there are multimedia
objects to there's there's a camera
there's audio which is both for input
and output there are various networking
module so there's two different USB
serial units the reason there's two one
of them is red and one of them is not
ready the ones that are red also provide
power and that will become important in
something and I'll tell you about in
just a minute but we have various radio
interfaces we have zigbee we have Wi-Fi
we have an ethernet interface we have an
860 eight megahertz radio you know so we
have lots of ways as I said one of the
things a very important about modern
gadgets is they can talk to each other
they can talk to the cloud we have ways
of making that easy we have storage
muzzles there's a slightly different USB
host module that allows you to plug
things like memory sticks and things
change a thing to get surge we also have
an SD card interface to allow you to get
storage lots of storage we have some
actuators or motor and servo control we
have some relay units that I haven't
shown here and there's ways oh this is
visit this is actually quite important
you can attach non gadget to your
hardware to your gadget here gadget if
you want you would use these lower level
hardware io modules in order to talk to
electronic devices that you bought from
someplace else that aren't actually
Gadgeteer much I'm going to that and we
have a few modules that we're still
building one of them that has a a gyro
and then accelerometer in the to do 3d
orientation and now these other two will
come back to why some of the modules are
red and some of them are you might think
why it wasn't one of the first things we
did build a battery because these things
are going to be devices you want to
carry in your pocket they should be
battery-powered it's a bit tricky when
we have external power modules as well
because lithium batteries explode if you
get back loaded so we just had to be
very because we want to get this widely
used we had to be very very careful to
engineer the battery unit so that it was
safe we have done that now and so there
is now a a a battery and likewise for DC
power from something like
car battery which we also wanted to
enable we just had to do it very very
carefully so that kind of take away
message here is we've already got a lot
of modules right you could build a lot
of stuff you can you know you probably
even just with this you'd be almost
unlimited in the types of things you
could build and I mean people early on
started building really really fun
things I mean this this is somebody I
don't camera will have to ask Nick
whether this was at maker faire or where
this was but somebody I know I'm like uh
suppers and built a line following robot
that's what this is this all just using
gadget here this is a line following
robot it has two of the RGB sensors on
the bottom of it to track black versus
white be able to track the line of the
robot it's got a camera on board to take
pictures while it does it it's got an
ultrasonic sensor on the front so it
doesn't bump the walls it's about two
short-range infrared sensors on the side
also to keep it from sort of bumping
into things and help its steer and
interesting it has a Wi-Fi module in it
which the software it talks to an azure
service in the cloud which then enables
it to be remote controlled from a
windows seven phone so this is this is
really quite something and you know that
whoever did this knocked it up fairly
quickly just using the just using the
gadgeteer stuff so you know you can you
can do some quite sophisticated things
for this already but just to give you a
flavor I'm going to show you a little
video of something much simpler well
Matt this is this is Nick Nick villor
who was the one who you with James Scott
debut of the m2 Torah this morning this
is a little video of somebody making a
camera see how long this takes so
there's the main board with be that USB
hosting on it that it looks like the
OLED display no no so that's the SD card
so you plug an SD card to store the
pictures of matts the co LED module we
need somewhere to some way to see the
pictures let's attach that what else do
we need we need we need a camera so
there's the camera module plug the
camera module in there into one of the
matching slots I don't know what letter
it is but there's several of them and we
need a shutter button now I think so
there's a button coming up let's add the
button now here comes the magic of
software let's hook it up to our own oi
in ngozi SD card first now the magic of
software and the power of that is plug
in the USB you'll see some lines showing
up in this
software being uploaded there and now
it's a camera press the button it takes
a picture that's Nick so there you go
from from nothing to a working digital
camera in very short order so that's the
you know that's the that's that let's
see that's the power of gadget you I
think it's really quite something now
the magic of software part the software
development environment for gadgets here
is based on the.net microphone so we
have this very powerful software
infrastructure behind this to make it
easy to use high level programming
languages rich libraries to to program
these things and you get the full power
of a vision studio ide when you're
implementing this and we've written and
an SDK with classes that encapsulate all
of the modules that we've done so far
and other lower level interfaces as well
so if you want to think of this in a
sort of software stack way the bottom
three there are essentially the dotnet
framework there's the the sort of the
clr which abstracts the hardware class
like the net framework class libraries
that goes on top of that and then the
stuff in orange is the code that you
would write as the as the gadgeteer and
but you do that using the green stuff
which we give you which is a whole bunch
of really rich library for every single
module there is there's a class that
lets you let you interact with the
module in you know any way that that
makes sense for that module for the
camera for the Wi-Fi so the guy who
wrote that line following robot must
have used the Wi-Fi module to write the
azure service to let it talk to the
cloud and so on but there are also these
lower level interfaces I squared C and
and sort of other things so as I said if
you have if you have a piece of hardware
that's not a gadget your module you can
still hook it up and use it as part of
your gadget you just use these slightly
lower level api's to to do that
and so we em we wanted to make it very
easy to program things so we really went
to town on building as much as we could
into Visual Studio to make it easy so
this is the kind of software engineering
type things that you'd expect but
something simple like they sort of
namespace alias so you the modules are
easy to find as you type the modules
that are available then come up and
they're their names are unabated so it's
pretty clear from the name what they do
but if that's not clear enough and you
hover you get in line help to see what
they do we have the thread safe event
model so you're not going to run into
too much trouble that way if you if you
stick to those into our you are on our
own software we also generate the event
handlers there's a bunch more there's a
lot of rich you know software
engineering things that we bring to
gadget here too I think they said we've
written a number of templates there's a
there's a basic application template
there's a couple of graphics application
templates a simple graphics one and
there so you can do there's a there's a
nice API for drawing very simple
graphics to that oled screen which lets
you build things like that camera very
quickly there's actually the full power
of the windows presentation framework
also available to you we have modules
for that so and you can choose whether
to use the simple or the or the or the
complex library depending on on what
level you're at you might use the simple
in person then dive into the more
complex than later as you build up your
gadget and we have we have examples to
about so let me give you another example
because I want to get into the third
aspect and we talked about the modular
hardware we've talked about the software
third example the third component is the
3d modeling side of thing but let's look
at another example so they task here get
24 hours to build a working tetris
handheld Tetris game Ian so first of all
let's build a hard row the hardware took
five minutes to build it's pretty much
like the camera very very simple what
what do we need we need a screen so we
can see the the Tetris pieces we need we
need the power source on these the
program and soccer like we always do
it's there we need a knob turning knob
so that we can rotate the pieces you all
know how to play tetris rights you you
want to rotate them as they fall we need
a knob
right we need one of those for way d-pad
game controller type switches to control
the placement of the piece right move
the back and forward ties Europe as
you're turning it as they drop and
that's all we need so it took five
minutes to plug this thing together and
away we go software of course not quite
so easy took a few hours to write the
software you can see you know there's
the method that rotates the piece I'm
won't go through exactly how it worked
cuz I'm not sure I'd be able to but you
can easily get the idea and the code
five hours is that's probably generous
actually but to write something like
this but so we write the software then
we build the case that we used
solidworks it's the it's the CAD package
that we've been using mainly for gadget
here at the moment and we've actually
built a plug-in for solidworks so that
as you design the case it automatically
tells you it knows about all of the
gadgetry modules so if you're using any
of those existing gadget here modules
the CAD package knows exactly how big
they are how they can fit together where
the bushes have to go where the mountain
killers go so that's all automatic you
don't have to worry about that so if you
as long as you know something about 3d
CAD you can build your model now there's
six hours now this is six hours when you
can do something else right this is six
hours of the 3d printer printing away to
build that case with all its sort of
bushings and things that you have
designed then you cut the case out you
put the whole thing together that takes
maybe half an hour and you have a
working hippest game now you may not
believe that it's working Tetris game so
I'll prove it here's Nick just in fact
last week when the period of me and
Emily there was a Leon respect but there
you go
that was built in 20 more hours in you
know it is until college as we hadn't
built the big battery modules by that
but now it would be able to be
completely nullified by that I don't get
rid of them and I guess I person should
but so the the aspect of the handheld
Tetris game that I think is interesting
is that physical design aspect and I
think that's where this gets really
interesting it takes us to a kind of new
place because you know another aspect
that is changing the world is the ready
availability of things that will turn 3d
designs into physical objects 3d
printing crc machines laser cutters all
very popular and there's two ways to do
miss you can buy one of these machines
yourself and they're no longer nearly as
messy as they used to be there's no
messy chemicals you know and you can or
but but if you don't want to be involved
with them at all there's tons of
companies where you can just upload your
CAD file and they'll post you the
regular thing a couple of days later
it's really quite something and this
thing lab is a place that does both of
those you can either buy the latest 3d
rendering sort of printers from from
them or they'll just take your CAD file
and send you something render and they
they have all sorts of different ways of
doing so they can send you things in
various materials not just plastic but
you know it this is really becoming
mainstream you go to the HP website and
they've got inkjet printers and they got
desperate printers and they got photo
printers and they've got 3d printers you
can just like just online now and they
this one is still this these are pretty
expensive this was about ten thousand
dollars i think but they're coming down
rapidly in price over there are other
companies that sell you can get a
reasonable 3d printer for under two
thousand dollars not face so this this
really is becoming mainstream so you
know we we wanted this kind of thing to
make it easier for us to build custom
enclosures for the gadgets that that we
were largely for our kind of rapid
prototyping exercises that I talked
about and as I said we've built a
plug-in for solidworks to make it easier
to to do this sort of an enclosure
design and we're planning to do the same
for other 3d CAD packages
it's not that hard as you can imagine
but let's think for a moment about you
know think about this aspect of gadget
here and where that might take us in the
future because there's a couple of
things happening first of all there's
lots of 3d design packages available I
think these are all free or almost free
the google sketchup is free 3d 10 is
free I love steps might not be free but
there's a lot of these 3d design
packages that are available that are
easy to use and Google's was actually
intended initially I think to make
models for google earth or four for the
BB thing and it's been co-opted and use
for all sorts of design but it's
particularly easy to use but and all of
these all of these things can be used to
generate files that can be either 3d
printing yourself or sent to one of
those one of those sort of in-house
printing agencies and then there's
companies like Shapeways now this is
also really interesting shapeways as a
company where you you design something
you design a bracelet or whatever else
it is you upload your design to
Shapeways and they will send you the
rendered thing and like thing loud they
have a bunt that they have 3d printers
and CRC machines and laser cutters they
can do it and also to the point but they
will send you a 3d rendering in whatever
material that build but but you want at
least of the ones that they can do so
you design a bracelet you say send me a
copper version of this bracelet in this
size great you get yours back attach the
sort of interesting here is that your
design stays on file and is public so
somebody else goes along says I like
that bracelet by I'd like it with my
name it I'd like it in this size click
it shows up in silver in your size with
your name on it and the person who
designed it gets a cup so there's this
there's a whole 3d design marketplace
going on that is that is just bound to
take off but again it gets better
because electronics are becoming
printable right there I think we can now
print conductors and transistors and
certain kinds of all LEDs it's not going
to be too long before you can just
upload an electronic design and have it
and have it printed using the same kind
of technology and put that in whatever
case that you've got so the kinds of
things that you can build with gadgeteer
will be able to be completely
manufactured on spec one at a time
tailored to how you want
so I mean I really think this is going
to be something new like we we may end
up in a world where we can specify
ourselves or Taylor somebody else's
design and create or by some of the also
design any kind of gadget you want that
is personalized to the two to our own
needs and that can be personalized in
the electronics that are in it in the
shape that it has in the whatever you
know in either is it a physical or
electronic weight and I think this is
this phrase that I put in italics is
really the key I think we're moving into
a world where hardware is now going to
start to evolve almost as fast as
software devs and that really changes
things for what software is all of it it
makes it a lot harder because you know
as with the pc it's probably going to be
the hobbyists and we'll know it is and
it will be the hobbyists and enthusiasts
and professionals like us who will be
doing this kind of thing first but
eventually you know your your your
grandmother could want a new type of
tracking device for your grandfather
who's has early stages of alzheimers she
goes to some said she says well it
shouldn't be you know it should be the
shape of the size or should have this
this like future that i want and she
might not writer herself but she can
specify it and bingo a new one would
show up and I you know this that's just
the tip of the iceberg because it also
doesn't have to be little yet these
could be big things like like circuses
would have been tailored in
manufacturers it's really quite quite
something I think I'm so yeah as I said
this and they'll be this there there is
actually starting to be and when the
electronics printing comes of age
they're really probably will be this new
on spec design and build on demand at
marketplace for others and a whole new
sort of marker place for people that
want to design these things as well as
as well as easily so i think that
building the software to drive this
world he's going to present us us in
this room a lot of challenges all I'm
interesting difficult and fascinating
challenges because it just makes it a
lot more complex in the old days you
kind of knew what the hardware wasn't it
wasn't going to change in the next month
you know might change over the next five
years just get faster like if there's
largely the same thing that you were
building for the same type of interfaces
whereas this the new interfaces all the
time right second one
other things like that so so and and
it's all gonna be talking to the cloud
like I said all this all this
communication and technology as well so
let's go back to this graph that I wrote
at the start and see what what this
means i guess just a way of sort of
illustrating what i said is that we are
now technology is moving on so much that
the blue line almost doesn't matter it's
going to carry on going up but we've got
a lot of room between the yellow line
and the blue i'm already so we've got a
lot of stuff we could do and i like to
think that this sort of personalized
gadgets idea even in the early days when
it's just being used by US will be a way
of letting us explore this boundary
between what we could do which is almost
anything and what we should do what will
make sense for us what will be good for
us you know aesthetically what we good
for us environmentally what will be good
for us socially all these things and you
know we can hopefully ring-fence an area
and just start building those other
things so so that's my kind of pitch for
for where the future is doing I'm going
to come back briefly to today now um you
know take my future all of his hat off
and just tell you tell you what's
happening with the edge here because
maybe you could be part of this this new
wave of stuff because we're we are using
gadget here for our own purposes as I
said so you know one example is we had a
project looking at making home heating
control better by predicting the
occupancy of rooms and we built a little
gadget that was put in each room of
several people's houses to do that and
we use gadget here for that and we hope
that you know some of you will want to
use that to cheer for research projects
like that and you'll you will be able to
because over the next few weeks the
agitator is going to be released as an
open source project so all the software
will come out under and apache license
of some kind i think all of the designs
the hardware designs will be coming out
on a Creative Commons license of some
kind again I believe and we're building
a big what we hope will be a big
community website to drive the interest
in me the sort of cross enthusiasm in
yeah and in terms of the hardware we've
we have a manufacturing partner who's
going to be building the main board and
a few of the modules I'm not sure
exactly which ones very soon so by I
think early summer could be able to buy
this stuff in li the starter kit with a
with a main board in a few modules will
be relatively cheap and more modules are
going to be coming up from that partner
and probably from others as well we hope
to really drive a big ecosystem around
this hardware manufacturers building
modules people you know people doing
experiments and driving the software in
an open-source fashion so so we're going
to be working with teachers university
teachers and high school teachers to
drive a hardware design curricula around
this idea there's a lot of interest in
that and if any of you is interested in
this you know please do get in touch
with us about that and let me put in a
little plug for the gadget here demo I
think Andrew mentioned but tomorrow
there's a demo fest you can come and see
Gadgeteer live those of you that weren't
at the tutorial this morning I think
that will give you a better flavor for
what it is and you can see you can see
for yourself whether you think that that
sort of image of the future that I
pitched will come to be or not but I
think at that I will love I will leave
it so thank you very much thank you too
to Nick and James who are actually here
who are very much behind the whole
Gadgeteer the whole gadgetry project and
Steve who also is involved innocent
manager and I believe now I hope this is
right Judith that but everybody got a
pepper no power board as part of their
path today they did go so I'm not going
to talk much about them if I cannot go
talk at all about that but this in terms
of this hardware software boundary
making hardware sort of easily
accessible the pepper mill project is
part of that it's basically a board that
will allow you to build a a
human-powered human interface device and
there is a post card that came with it
which will explain a little bit about it
but it will take can take you to a
website that will explain a lot of us so
so do have a look at that and thank you
very much
so are we so I mean I'm happy to take
I'm happy to take any questions you
might have and I guess do we need a
microphone for ya
hello this is the this is your paternal
partner my name is Mouse corrosion
bouquet gauge Sweden what are your plans
regarding this software the development
environment for instance this looks like
something that could rival the LEGO
robots and the National Instruments
software environment for programming
LEGO robots well okay so the question
revolves around the software development
environment can we bring down the 5
hours for getting a working camera down
to 10 minutes OIC plant so now can you
hear me now no I don't have former with
us i'll make that was the mic sorry i
hope you get hit the top I'm relating
this to the I'm relating this to the
national instruments like the LabVIEW
style they have for the LEGO robots yeah
i'm i'm aware i'm just i'm trying to
think of if you mean are we doing work
like you said if we could cut down that
sort of five hours now i don't know i
don't think other than than doing what
we can to make the the modules on the
software that goes with them as easy to
use in the current ID mean i don't think
we're doing any research on on sort of
programming techniques for this kind of
night now i would love it if some of you
out there would didn't kind of work you
know we really do want to make this a
sort of you know beachhead for a lot
more wickedness in this general area
because we can just
our self-worth I mean lip and james may
disagree but I don't think more
questions
yeah okay hi shyla Martin from Queen
Mary University of London i think is a
great fun you know i want one now to
play with but have a food what about
what about the dark side of all this
what about Tom build your own IED build
your own mini spy plane build your own
nasty stuff and all the people who might
be interested in building their own
nasty stuff yeah well that's I mean
that's acting quite a good point i guess
that's kind of you know what I meant
when I said that that yellow line can go
up and down it can obviously go very
much down now I I mean that's an age-old
argument though but technology being
used for good and bad things I'm not
sure you know I'm not exactly sure what
we can do to sort of address it as part
of this effort I mean we can certainly
as a sort of society caution against it
and I suppose try to do what we will be
good to to keep these things from the
news for bad purposes but I've not I
don't know it's just it's not see that
seems to me to be part of a much much
bigger question so if so to speak
somebody comes home go it comes come to
from Afghanistan goes into Macklin by
the box of this stuff and goes home
that's oh my god I guess I take your
point I'm just not entirely sure whether
you're saying that we simply shouldn't
do it for that reason or not I mean it's
a ya know it's only I it's a very valid
point and I maybe I didn't make it clear
enough when I was super strong the draft
but it's I do take your point okay Kim
last notebook University Denmark so do
you see this guy to cheer just as having
an educational purpose so do you see it
also as something that could be used in
a professional style to have you know
come up with quick prototypes and in a
professional environment say hospitals
or or factories or whatever where you
can see a need for new devices new
software yeah it's absolutely for both
of those things and and more but those I
mean those two that you highlighted are
the two real initial uses i think in
education it's it's going to be
tremendously done because it makes it so
easy for people to get their hands on
the hardware you know if you imagine the
old days I don't know whether you ever
had these sort of plug-and-play
breadboard things when you
to learn electronic but this is like a
much more sophisticated version of that
that lets you build things that can you
know where you can really start to
understand how the electronics interacts
with the software so I think that's very
important but on the other hand you can
you can build things that are robust
enough for real people to use and we're
certainly using them as I said in this
home heating project and we have a lot
of other projects where we think in
terms of doing rapid prototyping for
both experimentation but perhaps even
for a sort of early product evaluation
you could certainly use it for that so
yes I think I think both of those things
are are are where the initial
application will will be any other
questions no you can all go to the break
earlier if not yes thanks for a nice
talk I was just curious how difficult is
the programming for this gadgeteer stuff
do well i think i think for simple
things it's it's quite easy because all
the modules as i said expose quite a
natural sort of interface to how they
should be used i think if you want to
start programming hardware that is not a
gt-r hardware modules we get a lot
harder and so that's why we want to make
it extensible so that we can somebody
who maybe does that once could then turn
a new piece of hardware into a properly
supported gadgeteer module but you know
it's it's sort of hard to judge how easy
or not it is i think it's it's a lot
easier to build these kind of things now
than it would have been without the
gadgeteer modules that are sort of form
part of that software library but i
don't know whether that answers your
question or not would
yes the more skilled you are the more
complicated gadgets you can build that
just for instance would you be
conceivable to have an introductory
programming class based on gadgety
absolutely yeah yeah because I mean you
know you you can keep it very simple
building things like that game and the
camera is really quite straightforward
and that would be you know simp simple
things like that which nonetheless give
you the right kind of sort of
understanding the various aspects of
this this boundary between the hardware
and me and the software would be well
well well within the grasp of you know
late high school or early undergraduate
education absolutely Andrew oh dear
what's this it's a slightly self-serving
question like useful data and what
what's the kind of largest size object
you can practically making one of these
printing machines and how many objects
an hour can you make our at the moment
relatively small and relatively slow
right so i think i'm just trying thing
now you know Nick would probably be
better to answer this than me but the
one we have in the lab is probably
limited to something about I don't know
probably the size that you saw of that
some of that sort of cutouts for that
Tetris game so it's roughly solicits
said like a square foot and I don't know
how deep now I think the the larger
units that that the the agencies use
probably a lot larger than that but I
don't know what the you know I don't
think that you could build a second
light unit 3d printed at the moment you
have to 3d print the parts and then and
then and then assemble the but which is
which is also a fine way to design them
yeah actually there's a second party of
question the size and the and the time
the time is still relatively long as you
say as you saw I took six hours to print
that that fairly small one but as with
all these things the cost is coming down
the time is coming down as well but I
think when you're talking about physical
things you're up against some physical
limits where it will never get you know
obviously quite as fast with the
electronics
so I think personalization is great and
I think it's it's really important that
we do research that explores especially
you know things like things like
hardware customization and
personalization but I'm you concluded by
Suffolk waiting that hardware and
software would co-evolve and in some
sense but i'm just wondering whether
software has so many more degrees of
freedom so many more ways in which you
know you can actually change the
functionality of your gadgets that in
fact the the personal gadgetry
customization that you're talking about
or personalization is always going to be
a much smaller niche and that if people
are going to really specialize and do
something they want one something
they'll probably go to a professional to
do it whereas if they want to really
personalize and play around with
personalization software offers them so
much more ability to vary the scope of
what they do wonder if you know I'm not
saying I think you're exactly right I
think that hardware is never going to
catch up to softride I don't think it
can because it's because of its physical
nature but I think that that line is
going to move though I think you know
it's it's up you know prediction is hard
especially about the future actually say
so so who knows where this ignoble I do
think that that line is going to move
now how far it moves I don't know maybe
it won't move very far far at all in
which way your place maybe a little bit
a long way but they'll certainly I'm not
saying that hardware will ever evolve as
fast as software does but it's just
evolving and have the capability to
evolve so much faster than it did but I
think that that will cause a change in
there Ganesh gopalakrishnan from the
University of Utah when will we see a
person personalized open source
connected device that we can hack sort
of against it here I think I'm gonna
leave that question alone but uh but I
do take your point
hello Karen Hamels and of University of
Technology are very much liked it and I
tried it this morning but I do have a
question I have a background in design
and a few years ago people said well the
designer will be out of work but slowly
but certainly everyone will become a
designer what does this do for Microsoft
as a company will in the end to shift be
there more people get programming skills
and that's slowly but certainly the
character of Microsoft will be something
else more like a meta computer
scientists instead of the downward side
well again that's a very long range
long-range vision and I really I don't
know because i think i think there will
be some aspects of the the more
traditional software development that
will that will hang on I don't think
things like the you know your your PC at
home or your laptop are going to go away
I think the way they interact with these
devices that will build will change I
think the role of the designer is going
to increase I don't think it's Anna
dicus even if people are kind of doing
their own designs a really good designer
is still going to have a market and have
a much more readily a much longer tailed
market for what they do because of this
thing because of this marketplace that
is going to be enabled so that's what
might say
grateful I think on that very positive
note then it's a good place to end and
I'd like to thank him very much for his
inspiring talk and all the videos and
for telling us some things that probably
we never even thought about thanks Ken